the president also said yesterday he did
not know that his personal lawyer paid
one hundred and thirty thousand dollars
to adult film star stormy Daniels it was
the president's first public comment
about Daniels who says she had sex with
mr. Trump in 2006 the president also
said he doesn't know where the money for
the payment came from Paula Reed is at
the White House Polly good morning good
morning Daniel says that money she
received just days before the 2016
election was in exchange for her keeping
silent about her alleged affair with the
president but the White House has
repeatedly deny there ever was an affair
and yesterday the president denied
knowing about any payment
speaking to reporters aboard Air Force
one president Trump denied knowing about
the agreement negotiated by his personal
attorney Michael Cohen
he also denied knowing the source of the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
Daniel's told 60 minutes she had one
sexual encounter with mr. Trump in 2006
and was paid to keep quiet I was
concerned for my family and their safety
she is suing to invalidate the agreement
arguing the contract is not valid
because the president never signed it
she also argues their deal could have
violated federal election law you can't
be a party to an agreement have a
binding contract if you claim that you
basically didn't know about a principal
term a material term in the contract
Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
believes the president's denial helps
his clients case we think that the
president's comments today have not only
placed mr. Cohen in the crosshairs but
also subjected himself to significant
exposure for a deposition but Michael
Cohen spokesman David Schwartz has
denied the agreement with Daniels had
anything to do with the campaign's on
CBS this morning he said the money was
paid to protect mr. Trump's reputation
can I have a non-disclosure agreement
signed and go on with my life or am I
going to enter into a messy litigation
Daniel's attorney previously asked the
court to allow him to put the president
under oath for a deposition but the
judge rejected that requesting it was a
way too early in the process but after
yesterday's denial by the President
avenatti says he is going to try once
again to depose the president John Paul
I think seems like this process will
continue